- Hello, everybody.
Thank you so much for coming.
We're very grateful for your presence
at this lecture this afternoon.
I'm Kathy Rupp.
I'm the director of the
Council on East Asian Studies,
and we will be seeing a short video
that Professor Eric Greene
will tell you about as well.
He will be giving the
introduction of our honored guest.
- Thank you, Kathy,
for introducing the
introducer, as it were.
Thank you all for coming.
As Kathy said, I'm Eric Greene.
I teach in the Department
of Religious Studies
focusing on Buddhism in China,
one of a couple faculty there
in the area of Buddhist studies.
It's my great pleasure today
to introduce our speaker
the Venerable Jeongmok.
To ensure our time is used efficiently,
I'm just gonna say a few
words before we get started.
The Venerable Jeongmok stands
as one of the most eminent
senior female Buddhist
monastics in South Korea today.
She was ordained in 1978,
and, oh, sorry, 1976, excuse me,
and completed her Bachelor's
Degree in Zen Studies
and then a master's degree in social work
from Dongguk University,
which is also the institution
where my colleague,
professor Hwansoo Kim had
his undergraduate degree.
The Venerable Jeongmok has
served as a Buddhist chaplain
at the Seoul National University Hospital.
And in 1997 she founded
the Small Love Foundation,
which offers financial support to families
with children battling cancer.
She currently serves as the
abbess of Jeonggak Temple
in Central Seoul.
She's renowned for her
pioneering work in Buddhist media
and initiated a daily radio program
with the Buddhist
Broadcasting Service in 1990,
and later established the
Una Broadcasting Service,
which is a YouTube channel
with nearly a quarter million subscribers.
She was recently recognized as
one of the most influential
female Buddhist monastics
in South Korea today.
She's the author of
several bestselling books
written in Korean, including,
and I'm not sure where these translations
of the titles came from,
but I'm sure they're very accurate,
"Though the Snail is
Slow, It is Never Late,"
"The More You Empty
Yourself, the More You Have,"
and "Even Flowers Have to
Make an Effort to Bloom."
She's today gonna share
her life story with us,
and her talk will be translated
by one of our MA students,
Hyunghoon Cho who is around somewhere.
- [Speaker] Oh, she's coming.
- Who will come down when
that time, excellent.
And following the presentation,
there'll be lots of time,
I hope, for your questions.
Before we commence with the main activity,
I wanna just express my gratitude
to the council staff on the
Council of East Asian Studies
for all their efforts
in making this possible.
And before we welcome
the Venerable Jeongmok,
we are going to watch a
short two-minute video
that highlights some aspects of her work,
which I think will be queued
somehow miraculously now.
(audience applauding)
There we go.
(gentle music)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
(upbeat music)
(gentle music)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
(Buddhist clapping)
(gentle music)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
(Buddists vocalizing)
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
(Jeongmok laughs)
- Hello, nice to meet you.
- Hello, everyone.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
(Jeongmok laughs)
- Who made this video?
This is my first time seeing it.
(audience laughs)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- Actually, I'm not as great
as the video makes me seem.
- I'm so happy to be here.
This is the first time in my life
that I will been invited
to an American university.
So it is a very exciting time for me.
From the time I was invited
a year ago until now,
I will been so excited
and looking forward to meeting all of you.
And now I'm finally meeting you all.
I don't speak English very well.
I want to greet you in English.
I practiced a few lines.
So I decided to speak in Korean
and have someone translate for me.
I talk to you in Korean from now on, yeah.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- [Translator] People actually call me
the mother of healing in Korea.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I'm not even married,
and I've never had a child.
(audience laughs)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Do I look like a mother?
(Jeongmok laughs)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
For a long time I've
wondered why people call me
the mother of healing.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Even when I was 30,
a 50-year-old man once called me mother.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
He was crying, and he ran into
my arms like a young child.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I hear some people call Yale University
with its 300-year history,
the mother of American universities.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
What does mother mean
to all forms of life?
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Mothers are people we can truly trust,
trust the most after being
born into this world.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Moms are a symbol of
our faith in this world.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
People want to be protected
from a fearful world.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Everyone wants to rely on
someone and be cared for.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I think people wanted to
find that sort of trust
and care in me.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Maybe I reminded them of their mothers.
That is probably why
they called me mother.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
In that respect, I am very
thankful for that title.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I feel very, very grateful.
But I too feel fear sometimes.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And I have one particular
experience with fear.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
In 1981, before most of the
students here were even born-
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I left to practice deep in the mountains,
and I was 21 years old at the time.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
The temple was a small shabby cabin,
deep in the mountains in the countryside.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I knew it was senior monk there,
so I set off for it with
my friend, a fellow monk.
And the way to that temple
was incredibly rough.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
There were no roads,
and we had to go through a thick forest
and cross a deep river.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Do you know those rivers
with strong churning
waters like a whirlpool?
We had to cross that to
get to the hermitage.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
So I took off my shoes and
threw it across the river.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And I took off my coat and
threw it across the river.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I took off my sack and
threw it across the river.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Had to jump and land.
I had to land well,
sort of like Spider-Man
in today's Marvel movies.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
So back then, we fearlessly
set off for a place
where we could die while
crossing the river.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
But we arrived at the temple safely,
and my friend left two days later,
and I stayed there for about a month.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
It was so deep in the mountains
that no one ever really came by.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
It was, in short, in the middle of nowhere
where it was hard to see even
one person for an entire year.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And one day we ran out of rice,
so my senior monk had to leave
for the village to get some.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
She left early in the morning
and told me she would be back by noon.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And I was left all alone in the temple.
Noon came, and I was in the
kitchen scooping up some rice
for lunch when I suddenly felt
that there was someone behind me.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
You know, it was kind
of that eerie feeling,
and my nerves were very on edge.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
So I slowly turned around
as if nothing would matter,
and I looked back.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And I saw three or four strangers,
very big men standing
in front of the door.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Now, this was a place
where nobody ever came to,
but these people were snake catchers.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
They looked at me and said,
"Sumim, please give us some water."
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Now, there were no houses
around the hermitage.
So back then we used to drink
directly from a nearby stream.
So I gave them a gourd and told them
that's what they should do as well.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
After drinking the water,
the men thanked me and left.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
As soon as they disappeared,
I felt an immense wave
of fear come over me,
and I started trembling.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I ran into the Dharma Hall,
and I latched all the doors,
and I put a Korean style
spoon onto the door handle
to latch it.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I was so afraid that I hid myself
in the innermost corner of the room
because I was scared of
my shadow being visible
if I was near the door,
which was made of paper.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I pulled the blanket
over myself and trembled.
My heart was racing,
and I was so scared that I
couldn't think of anything.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I forgot my hunger and the need to eat,
and I was completely
unaware of the time passing.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Fear took over my entire body,
and the senior monk who
said she'd be back by now
still hadn't returned.
And I just stayed there shaking with fear.
And before I knew it, the sun
had set, and it was evening.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
It was 1981,
so we didn't have any
electricity in those mountains.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And it started to get
dark outside the window.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I had not done anything for half a day
because I was so overwhelmed with fear.
But at that moment, a
thought occurred to me.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
It was like a light bulb
lighting up brightly in the dark.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
It had been a long time
since those people had gone.
So why am I still scared?
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
What is it that I'm afraid of?
The moment the thought occurred,
my fear completely disappeared.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
The world became clear as
if a veil had been lifted.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
It was then when I was 21-years-old
that I realized my fear was in
my thoughts and in my heart.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
To be more precise,
it was my mind that was creating the fear.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Only then did I finally
pull back the blankets.
I got up, and I saw the moonlight
shining into the room through my window.
And when I saw this, my mind felt at ease.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Do you remember that spoon I
latched to the door handles?
I removed the spoon, opened the door,
and came out of the room.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
How can I even explain this feeling?
This was in the middle of summer,
but when I went out into the yard,
the moonlight was so white,
it was as if white snow had
covered the entire yard.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
There was also a pine tree in the yard,
and its shadow was swaying in the wind.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And so I wrote a few lines about
what I felt in that moment,
which later became the lyrics to a song
called "Wendy Hermitage."
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Wendy Hermitage, you
probably didn't even know
this song existed.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Of course not, right?
The funny thing is this song
became the most popular song
among Korean Buddhists for 30 years.
Isn't that surprising?
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Honestly, I don't really
know how that happened.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
The lyrics of this song
capture the fear that froze me
in my youth, as well as
the realization that came
in the moment that I broke free from it.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
It was the first time
that I truly understood
that I am the one creating the fear,
and that I am the only
one who can recognize
and overcome this.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
This is the first few lines of the song.
Should I sing it?
(Jeongmok laughs)
(audience applauding)
(Jeongmok singing in Korean)
(Jeongmok singing in
Korean continues)
(audience applauding)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
So I just sang a first
few lines of the song,
and I know that nowadays this
may not be your cup of tea.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
We think we know our own minds,
but in reality we really don't.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And that is why I wrote these
words, I can't draw my mind.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And perhaps the same goes for fear.
Fear is an emotion that
we feel instinctively
in the process of caring for
and protecting ourselves.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
You may have heard of this,
but in neuroscience, the area of the brain
that triggers the flight
response in our moments of fear
is called the amygdala.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
We need this in order to take
care of ourselves properly.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
However, when this fear becomes
excessive, it overwhelms us.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Then we see nothing but fear.
When the moment of fear passes,
there is no need to
dwell on it any longer.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
When a gazelle sees another gazelle
being eaten by a cheetah,
it may be very shocked in that moment,
but after that moment passes,
it will not dwell on that
fear, it will move on.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
The same is true of good things as well
because we can't remain perpetually
in a state of excitement.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Whether it is fear or something we like,
what we need is something
called attention recovery.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
When something happens,
you should focus your attention on it,
but when it's resolved, you
should withdraw that attention.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
But many people find this difficult
recovering your attention
from if whatever is
making you afraid or
whatever is making you happy.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
For example, when you
feel a negative emotion
towards someone else,
you will continue to
pour your energy into it.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
You think about it when you get home
and sometimes even dream about it,
and that is where you
pour all your energy into.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
If you don't recover your attention,
you'll continue to drain your energy.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And that's probably
why people get so tired
and so easily lately.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
When something bad happens,
there's no use in asking
why this happened.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Let's say that a tornado comes
and blows your house away.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
No one can answer the question
of why your house was blown away
while the house next door was fine.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
It's important not to dwell
on why these things happen,
but to think about what
steps you should take next
and focus your attention
on resolving the situation.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
In this respect, life is just like a game.
We sometimes ask questions
like, why was I born,
and blame our parents or our society
for things that happened to us.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
But there is no answer to the
question of why we are born.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
The moment we are born,
the game of life begins.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Once the game has started,
you need to live and act
by the rules of the game.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
All we can do is think
about how to do our best
with what we've been already given.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
If we enter the playing field,
and the ball comes
flying in our direction,
we need to catch it quickly
and pass it on to someone else
instead of asking questions like,
why is the ball flying towards me?
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
We can't be asking questions like,
what am I supposed to do with this ball?
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
So when the game begins,
don't just look around,
start moving.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Depending on the stage of your life,
the rules and the playing
grounds will continue to change.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And we just need to continue
playing according to our rules.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Just because we lose one game
doesn't mean your life is over.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
You will always get another
chance, and that is life.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
From the moment we are
born, we grow as we age.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
But there are two paths in life.
One is a horizontal path, and
the other is a vertical path.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
The horizontal path is a life
that progresses laterally
as one ages through
infancy, adolescence, youth,
adulthood, and old age.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
The word horizontal here means that
although you may grow older in age,
you remain on the same level,
only moving from side to side.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
This path is living a life full
of sensuality and distrust,
desire and anger.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
On the other hand, the
vertical path is a life
in which you grow by actively leaping,
uproot through infancy,
adolescence, youth,
adulthood and old age.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And this path becomes filled
with the exploration of life.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
In this kind of life, you get older,
and you're getting more experience,
and you are not easily swayed.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Rather, a life becomes more beautiful
with each passing year.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Just because you lose once
doesn't mean everything is over.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
You'll always get another
chance even if this one passes.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
That is life.
So believe in yourself.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And you also need to love yourself.
Don't forget that you are the
main character of this life.
- Remember, life is on your side.
Thank you for listening my story.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- [Speaker] Any questions
from the audience?
(Jeongmok laughs)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- Should we end this if there
are no further questions?
(audience laughs)
- Yes.
- [Audience Member] For
people who aren't monastics
but who are practicing Buddhism,
how do you think we can most meaningfully
make that a part of our life
when we have so many distractions
and so many pressures put upon us to,
especially in like a university,
keep up with other statuses
of status, and career, and all of that.
(translator speaking in Korean)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- So I don't think there's a separate path
that practitioners need to take.
It doesn't matter if you're
in a temple or a university.
What matters is what you do
in your current situation,
what you decide your mind.
- I was very captivated by your thoughts
about attention control and retaining,
regaining attention control.
And I think it's particularly
important in digital times
when we are so much
engaged and being engaged
into giving away our attention
in this economy of attention.
For those who do not
practice, just ordinary us,
are there any ways you could tell us to
function better under these circumstances?
(translator speaking in Korean)
- Good question.
(Jeongmok laughs)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- So you don't need to practice Buddhism
in order to control yourself, your life.
We all want to live a better life.
And the reason why we
consume so much information
is because we want to know more.
And what's really important here
is to turn your attention
to your inner self.
We need to take, we need
to discard of the labels,
like oh, Buddhist practitioner.
Whether we are Buddhist
practitioners or not,
the important thing is to turn
and look at your inside, your inner self.
- For example, computer.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- So when you're looking at
information on a computer,
try to be aware of the very
act of looking on the screen
and think about who is looking at what,
the subject and the object of the gaze.
And try to think, try to
focus on what exactly is it
that I want to gain from this information.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Do you play a lot of online games?
(audience laughs)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Then you have nothing to worry about?
- Yes.
- I've been practicing
Buddhism for a few years,
not as much as I would like to,
but I have found it very important
to be very present in the moment.
And I found that active
practice takes effort.
And I very much appreciate
what you said in your story,
but in today's society, when
we have the conflicts we have
with Israel and Hamas, I want
to be present in the moment,
but I also wanna respect what is happening
and to consider that.
So how do you reconcile those two?
You know, I obviously have to live
and go throughout the day,
but I feel for the people so much.
(translator speaking in Korean)
- Oh yes, yes, yes.
Yeah.
May the victims rest in peace, yeah.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- War is not something
that should ever happen.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And we have been through so
many wars throughout history.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
But we still haven't learned from it.
It's because of foolishness and ignorance.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Even if there are personal or
national benefits through war,
that nothing is more important than life.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
We won't be able to
stop war through anger.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Being angry and wanting revenge will,
you can't stop it with more anger.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
You can only end anger with compassion.
But when war is happening, we
all feel pain for the victims.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
But what we really need to
focus on in that moment-
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
We need to be focusing on what we can do
in our current situation.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Beethoven continued to compose
music during World War II,
even when bullets were
flying over his head.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And war reporters know
that there is a very real chance of death,
but they're still there
in the thick of it.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
No matter all the terrible
things that happen in this world,
we need to be aware of where
we are and what we need to do.
- It's okay.
Thank you.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- Thank you for sharing.
- Okay.
- Thank you so much for your time today.
I think we all really appreciate it.
My question was, in your experience,
what is the most effective
way to learn about Buddhism?
(translator speaking in Korean)
- Okay.
(Jeongmok laughs)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- Are you interested in Buddhism?
- Do you like (Jeongmok
speaking in Korean)
(Jeongmok laughs)
- Do you like Buddhism?
- Buddhism.
Yes, thank you.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- It's very simple to,
the easiest way of knowing
Buddhism in your everyday life
is very simple.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Make others happy the
way you want to be happy.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Just like you want to avoid pain,
avoid inflicting pain on others.
- That's it.
(audience laughs)
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, hi.
First of all, thank you so much
for your lovely talk and your story.
I just wanted to ask a question about,
we covered a little bit about fear,
and especially here in the West, we have,
whether it's the media industry,
there's like a profit
profiting off of fear.
There's a utilization of
fear systematically to,
whether it's to divide people
or to, you know, fund or create
support for wars, you know,
get in the face of this
systemic rise of fear,
not only individually within people,
but like from the institutions itself.
How do you think we should
take a more systematic approach
to tackle this growing rampant fear?
(translator speaking in Korean)
- Oh, very difficult question.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- I mean, I can't do much about it.
- Yeah, but.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- What I would like to
say is don't be too swayed
by all the information that
you receive from the outside.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
The outside is just the outside,
whether it's the media or the news.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
You need to be firm and not swayed.
Elephants don't fall even when
they receive a lot of arrows.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Your inner self, you need to be firm.
So even if there is a
war going on outside,
if you maintain peace and
calmness within yourself,
and everybody sort of contributes to that,
we will be able to
contribute to the world.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Thank you for thinking about the world.
- [Audience Member] Hi,
thank you very much.
I'm gonna relay this in English
'cause I don't know how
to say this in Korean.
I'm really captivated by the
concept of attention reset
and attention recovery.
But really what are the
best ways to apply that
in moments of joy and happiness?
I think that's something that
I'm still trying to understand
is kind of, you know, in moments of fear,
moments of, you know, just
of trouble and challenges,
I understand,
and I think like just
it's in our nature to,
at least it's in my nature to, you know,
want to have apply that
attention recovery.
But I'm just trying to figure
out how I can apply that
in moments of joy as well.
(translator speaking in foreign laughing)
(Jeongmok laughs)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- When we're happy and joyful,
we want to stay that way.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
But in reality, if you think about it,
it's harder to recover your
attention in moments of fear.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And if you're unlucky, It
could also lead to death.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And even joyful things,
things that make you happy,
if it's in excess, it
could also lead to death.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
So in Buddhism we practice mindfulness.
And the reason for that is
to avoid these two extremes.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
There's no good no bad.
If we put an end to those two extremes-
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
We'll be able to know that joy and fear,
neither are eternal.
- I really appreciated that analogy
about life being a game,
and when you get thrown a ball,
you just have to catch it quickly
and throw it to someone else.
But practically, what does that mean?
I think it's very easy as
college students especially
to get stuck in the question of like,
what do I do with this ball?
So how do we know to just throw it?
(translator speaking in Korean)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- Are you a college student?
- Okay.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- So when people are born, we
have 800 bones in our body.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And as we grow, they fuse into,
fuse with each other to form
206 bones by the age of 30.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
So for our brains, between
the ages of 25 to 30,
the neurons, our neurons will be covered
by this thing called myelin.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And you haven't gotten to that stage yet.
You're still growing.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Don't be afraid to
explore and make mistakes.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
(audience laughs)
Go through a lot of
trials and tribulations.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
The most interesting in
life is about the trials.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Look at sports athletes.
They go through a lot of trouble,
and then before finally
winning that gold medal.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Don't be afraid of the
waves that come at you.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
When you're afraid,
tell yourself that it's okay
and everything will pass.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And this is something that I mentioned
at the Buddhist Student Community event
that we had yesterday.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
In America we have the
Yosemite National Park.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And when I went there 20 years
ago, there were so many trees
that were 2,000-5,000 years old.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And I bought a seed there.
And the seed was very, very small.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I put it on top of my fingernails,
and I rubbed it, and it was
just gone without a trace.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
But imagine that great tree all started
from the tiniest seeds.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
When you feel worried, you
feel that you are very small.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
But there is a great tree
waiting to grow inside of you,
and you are that kind of seed.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Don't worry about it.
Please remember, go through
those trials and tribulations
and keep exploring.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
It is the best part of life,
and it's great for you
to grow as a person.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I went through a lot of
trouble after being ordained,
but that's made into who I am today.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I became a nun at 16.
What could I have known at that age?
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I told them that I would bear
whatever burden that comes my way.
- Thank you.
Hi, thank you again for coming
and speaking to us today.
I also had a question about the game of,
how you described the game of life.
What would you say to
someone who might like
be tired of the game of life
and not really want to like keep playing?
Yeah, I think that's it.
(translator speaking in Korean)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- That is one decision you can make.
But if we have to make that
decision among all the options,
wouldn't it be better to choose the option
to keep continue playing that game?
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Of course you might feel like
you don't want to do anything.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And it's okay not to do
something at the moment.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
That's not a problem
when it comes to life.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Are you personally sort of
troubled by that kind of stuff?
- No, one of my friends is.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- Would you be able to share
more about that kind of feeling?
- Yeah, I mean, like they
often tell me that it's like
you like kind of go through things,
and you don't really know
why you're doing everything.
And like if it would
just be better to like
stop playing the game of life, yeah.
(translator speaking in Korean)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- There are a lot of young people nowadays
who think the same things.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
There are so many in Korea.
Perhaps we think about
those kinds of things
because the world has become
a better place to live in.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
There is no particular meaning to life.
We create our own meanings.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
You need to be able to put in the effort
to create that meaning.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And you want to help
your friend through this?
- Yeah, of course.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- Sometimes that thing,
those kind of things arise
out of a sense of
superiority or inferiority.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
But in reality there's no
one who's like better than us
or worse than us.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Does your friend take any
kind of like medication
for that stuff?
- No.
- No, okay.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- Maybe you can suggest meditation.
- Okay.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- Do you think they'll
be interested in that?
- Honestly I don't think so, but.
(translator speaking in Korean)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- What about sports?
- No.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
(audience laughs)
- Then there's nothing I can say.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
So you gave me a very good question,
and I'd like to introduce a book
by a Yale professor called Marc Brackett.
- Permission to Feel.
- Permission to Feel, Marc Brackett.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- This is by Professor Marc
Brackett of Yale University,
and it's also been translated into Korean.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I was very moved after reading this book,
and I met the professor earlier today.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
It hasn't been long
since we've been living
with our emotions,
and we've actually lived for a long time
without feeling those kinds of emotions.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Apparently emotions as we know it
have only been in existence
for the past 15,000 years.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Depression, anxiety, fear, all
these emotions are in reality
what humans have created for themselves.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
So that means we can also learn
to control those emotions.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And this book sort of explains
those kind of techniques
that we can use to control those emotions,
and it's been a great help to me.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
I would very much like to
recommend this book to you all.
- Thank you so much for
sharing your lovely story.
You mentioned that we should
choose to grow vertically
as opposed to horizontally as we age
from infancy through old age.
And my question to you is,
what are we growing towards?
So to put it differently
in Buddhist teachings,
what is considered a good
life before you end your life?
(translator speaking in Korean)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- Have you studied or know
anything about Buddhism?
- I'm not a practitioner, but
I am very much interested.
(translator speaking in Korean)
- Okay.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- So Buddhism suggests two things.
So what's the difference
between animals and humans
is that we have that ability to perceive
and understand things.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And that's why we put in the effort
for our own personal growths.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And that's why we also help others
to achieve their own growths.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
So we learn about both of these things,
learning from the growing for ourselves
and helping others grow in Buddhism.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
So this term grow is actually
used in English circles,
and it's not a term
that we use in Buddhism.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And I just use the term growing
to make it easier to understand.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
In Buddha, we teach that each
of us are our own Buddhas.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
Buddha isn't something
that exists outside.
The Buddha is within all of us.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
But we tend to think of ourselves
and the Buddha as separate.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And so we continue looking for the Buddha.
But in reality we are the
Buddha sitting right here.
- Okay.
Finish it?
Okay.
- Thanks for all the sharing.
I think I just have a simple question.
So after practicing
Buddhism for so many years,
what do you look forward to every day?
(translator speaking in Korean)
(Jeongmok laughs)
- Very nice question, yes.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- So when I became a monk-
(Jeongmok and translator
speaking in Korean)
So I was very enamored about
the vows made in Buddhism.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And I was very enamored
by all the great teachings
that I had never even seen in school.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
So there is a vow in Buddhism where
I want to be the medicine
for someone who is ill.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
There is a vow that where
I want to become a bridge
or a boat for someone who
is trying to cross a river.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
So when I see these
vows, I feel very moved.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
The fact that I can be
this kind of person,
and the fact that I am
that kind of person.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
So when I pray every morning,
I pay my respects to
those great teachings.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
To those beautiful teachings.
- Okay.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
- [Audience Member] Thank you so much.
(audience member speaking
in Korean)
- [Audience Member] I
have one more question.
- What did you say?
Ah, yes.
(audience member speaking
in Korean)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- Okay, I don't know,
maybe I can, you know,
explain exactly or not,
but yeah, I'm Korean,
as moved to the here little
bit more than 20 years ago.
When I came here I saw your profile.
Then one of your, the
name of the book More,
"Getting More Empty,
You Can Get More Full,"
something like that, right?
(audience member speaking
in Korean)
- Okay.
- So the question was about
how do you empty yourself.
Because when he read one of Sumim's books,
and he was very captivated by the title
because the title is "The More You Empty,
The Fuller it Gets."
And when he received his
Dharma name in Korea,
his dharma name means emptiness.
And so he tried reading
the flower Garland Sutra,
but it was too hard,
and he couldn't read it,
and he still doesn't really
know how to empty yourself.
And the question was about that.
- Okay.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- Have you heard of the Gestalt theory?
- No, okay.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- So in the night sky, when we see stars,
we say that the stars are twinkling.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
But in reality we're not
looking at the stars,
we're looking at a dark night sky.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
We need that dark night sky
in order to see the stars.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
You can't separate the
stars from the dark sky.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And there is hatred because there is love.
And there are farewells
because there are encounters.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
We have this because
there is that and other.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
And that is Buddhism.
And to know that is to know emptiness.
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- Is this-
(audience laughing)
(Jeongmok speaking in Korean)
- Yes, thank you.
- On that note, please give
her a big round of applause.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you so much.
Thank you.
(gentle music)